dan how do you know when your film is
festival ready well I mean I don't know
if it's uh I don't know if it's festival
ready is really the right word I think
it's uh I'm gonna be honest it's the
quality of the film right I mean if the
film is is of the best calibrate that
film can be like if the film is like if
the filmmakers intent was to make a say
a short story about a child's first love
you know in school or you know I'm
storming random you know if that story
is told the best way possible and it is
in his complete and it's a strong film
then Dennis s already know I mean I fit
every festival
you know there's festivals every jet
films like getting two really good
festivals and then sometimes you you
know we've had an instance where one
time we rejected a film and they wrote
back home I got into this vessel that
festival there's a tune really did not
relate it I mean they're not related
it's two separate things what we look at
is what we're looking to program is
separate of course than any other
festival right I mean we handle what we
handle we have a certain policy we have
a certain way of judging films and other
festivals have theirs but if a film is
very good and completed and done to the
best it can possibly be
then that's stressful right I mean know
whether it's every festival or not
that's a whole different I guess
questionnaire discussion but that's my
way of looking at miss festival ready I
mean we look at certain films and then
we make decisions based on what we feel
is the best film or films for the
festival for the program and that's how
we make our decision I mean it's to make
it more like to make it more simple in
simple terms so you know it's kind of
that it's it's basically if you feel the
film is of the best caliber it can be
for that story in for that film then I
guess was already I mean you know I know
it doesn't really answer it in a certain
way but it's it's that's how I look at
it like the festival ready or not as
more just is the film the film was not
good and we feel is not up to up to par
then essentially it's not festival
regular at least for us know maybe for
other festivals they might look at it
differently but that's that's kind of
that's how we look at that if you had a
friend who was a filmmaker and let's say
they were rejected by a festival would
you encourage them to follow up with a
letter polite letter just inquiring as
to well hey you know why was this sir
you know maybe can you take a second
look or or is it best to just sort of
let the chips fall where they are
no I think it think it's good to be as
aggressive as possible I mean I wouldn't
say like take a second look because you
know it's just to be quite honest I it
won't happen I mean I don't see
programmers all right let me take that
back maybe some well I'm there's
instance that we've even had our early
years we were like kind of learning the
programming and we were growing so we
all of a sudden in seven days the
program and you know early on we we
actually programmed for a certain amount
of films and we realized we went back we
notified everyone of everything and then
we looked we said Oh actually we need
another like a few hours of programming
another program to fill so we were short
so we actually did have to go back and
reevaluate some of those films that were
on the cusp of getting in and actually
ended up notifying them but they didn't
we notify them in there and so we ended
up putting them in after we totally were
not so that happens sometimes but they
didn't follow up and say oh put me in a
war you know take a second look or so it
wasn't like we respond to that per se
but it was a situation where we actually
had to go back after tell them they
didn't get in
and Tom's our you know our error and we
actually you know decided to program the
film and that and that's you know and
it's not really that awkward because
it's great you know they're happy to get
in we're happy that we can program the
film's and get them in and you know I
wouldn't say there was mistakes made it
was just a learning process of the time
we had to fill and I had a program and
now that we know what we're doing as far
as the programming and our link to the
festival that doesn't happen anymore but
but uh but yeah so I think went back to
the point of following up it's always
good to get on people's radars I mean no
matter what if he doesn't get responded
to okay we get emails all the time like
that and sometimes we get the respondent
to be born in the I'm dialogue and and
sometimes we don't want to be made miss
some emails but I think it's good I
struck I mean you know why not you know
I mean but again I don't know what scene
he was second look there's a very rare
opportunity that happening but it is
something that where you can get
feedback you can get feedback you know
people know will tell people when we can
you know certain feedback about the film
you ask in a good way you know some
people get a little more upset when they
write certain emails and that's and
we're not gonna really we're not
responding to that I just it's it's not
something we want to I'm gonna go down
that path I'm thinking that negativity
you wanna if people ask the more
respectful way and looking
sort of criticism that someone would
like to try to try to do if we can so
yeah so you know it's I said yeah it's
good it's good to follow up I mean again
it's it's why not you should always try
to follow through when it comes to the
festival we like filmmakers in more and
in tune to the film to the festivals and
also and like paying attention to what
we're doing and I really like eager to
reach out and are more eager to like
participate you know then someone who
just really doesn't pay any attention or
visits any emails or is not very
responsive you know we like the
interaction so I think there's something
to be said for people who are you know
to put themselves out there and are
giving a shot you know what would you
say is the ideal length of a short film
that's it's hard I mean I everybody says
like 15 minutes and yeah no because I
mean we have films are five minutes
seven minutes that are like incredible
that films are any number of lengths are
or even in the 20s and the 30 minutes
that are incredible films the film is
great and again I was going back to this
if the film if it's set out no matter
give us 30 minutes for us or 30 minutes
or under so no some other like the
academy is is longer I think it's 40
minutes if a film this is it just a
that's right way if it's it's the story
is if it's complete the film's you know
done very well with the production value
and shot very very well the actors are
great stories good so story is told that
you know the essentially the goal is
reached the story they want to tell has
been told in a very very strong manner
then it doesn't matter the length we
look at it like that I mean I don't want
to I don't want to program looking at
something that's 30 minutes saleable you
know that's really good but it's it's
long you know it's just 30 minutes if we
feel the film it holds up against any
other film especially for its category
we have to program that film over others
first we don't want to like bump that
film out because well you know what it's
it's too long now granted it does take
into effect sometimes that films that
are are on the cusp whether it's they
got great a little lower and it's hard
to get in and you only this much time
yeah we left the program like a film or
two that's 15 minutes in length as
opposed to 30 minutes so you can't fit
it in that program you know say for
instance we have a drama you know maybe
drama category and it's a and we already
have an hour-and-a-half program we only
have two
not the program for that slot but yes if
a film is grated equally with another
film that could weigh it you know then
we can't fit it just doesn't fit so I'll
have to push that aside and might not
make it in but uh you know it's it's
it's again I feel like if the story
story and acting or two things I feel
are very important you know that films
were watching if the actors aren't
astronomer is not holding up your
stories falling apart I mean you know
you you know those attention and the
film will just knit will not be will not
be very good and story-wise the story's
important as well it's like you know you
people that have an idea it looks good
and shot well yeah this looks great
and then the story doesn't take you
anywhere and it just kind of lags see me
be a seven-minute film but it feels like
it's 30 minutes and and and the action
doesn't move forward and it isn't it's
not telling the story if you feel it was
intended to tell them so that's you know
then there you go so the runtime kind of
doesn't matter you know it's like it's
more about there's a story itself in the
film itself and the runtime so I kind of
look at did the quality the quality of
film again is it more important if you
like if you feel like a story was told
well for the means they had and all that
and that's that's most important but the
general sense for does help to have
short films if it feels really good and
it's short that's gonna be easier to
program clearly there's gonna be space
for it and it's gonna be easier to slot
in the program so you know yeah is that
was a similar for documentary films yeah
yeah I mean it's some way you have
someone but documentaries tend to run
longer you know most adults beginner or
longer in length
you know they're usually not too short
because obviously diving into a your
subject matter maybe we're trying to
tell a story about a situation and
documentary the nature can't be too
short right I mean you don't get trying
really get into a story and getting to
know some was live life or lives or you
know if it's a situation about you know
some some things say you know the
factory workers getting laid off in the
town and how it affects the town you
have to get into the story and really
get to meet the people to really
understand the scope so those films are
generally longer so that that is a
programming challenge because we only
usually have two programs max for
documentaries sometimes even one so
that's what two hours or four hours to
fill
and that's it so if you have five films
or 30 minutes and like that's already
your refills you filled in tamil party
so that makes it challenging on that
front but those ones have to be that way
I mean again documentaries you know
different nature so they kind of have to
be a little bit longer you know
generally the good Doc's have seen there
are many things that you said to us in
the past is that you're not comfortable
handing over the duties of screening
films to an intern even though it means
a very overwhelming amount of time and
work that you have to put in and watch
every film I know you guys got so many
submissions and it's increased
dramatically over the years so after
eight years why is that so important to
you still that you both you and Theo
play such a vital role in watching you
know it's a also we enjoy you know I
mean I mean titsingh for getting to any
else's it's fun we love movies so you
know is a good time to watch it's a kind
of fun like it's a cool process like to
sit down you don't know what you're
gonna see like every year we don't know
what the hell are we missing
you can see you know you see this and
obviously read the stuff but now you put
them on you're gonna find something
every year something new refreshing the
school thing about these shorts feature
films made for two things one are made
for different reasons right I mean you
know they're made for distribution to
sell commercial viability you know
whereas shorts are not so much I mean
they have changed with all the different
platforms and distribution or whatnot
and online but still the short film is
still more of a calling card is your way
of telling the story you want to tell or
a unique story it's a different kind of
medium it's a different filmmaking it's
different genres so it's not the right
right work but it's different on the
other so making shorts filmmaker has a
different latitude of creativity whereas
you know the feature film they're made
for you know those more specific reasons
the more even again business sense why
right it's like it's when they're made
again to sell or you know for
distribution or just you know for that
that with that in mind you know
specially the money you're spending the
times then you know the short you can
make maybe a really cool
a few days just a feature film is not
some little two-day process so you know
what was shorts that's the cool thing so
for us to sit down to watch these films
you know we're finding you know really
cool voices a new creativity like every
day we said I don't watch it you know
much of films and so that's one part of
it it's the enjoyment of that you know
they kind of find something new you know
it's just you watched films all day you
spent a whole day watching movies and
maybe nothing is really hit and you're a
disappointed and you know they're not
going well you know the judging process
you have that some days that you know
the films a lot of submissions down that
of course not all when we're getting in
it and then you see that one film was
just like just a Wow
you know it just kind of hits and that's
that's really neat to kind of look like
you found it you know it's like the kind
you'd only haystack kind of I guess
metaphor or whatever but that's part of
it but to you know we want to know what
we're coming up with you know what is
coming our way we want to know what we
have I mean it's still our thing it's
our festival it's our name behind it
right so it's important for us to know
what we're screening and know every kind
of essentially everything you know if we
come out there we're out the festival I
don't wanna be there so you know I don't
know what these movies are anybody that
could be the case right if I passed a
bunch of stuff on and we didn't see
anything I've never got chance to watch
some of these films Pepa thetic elite
maybe we would never watch some of these
films you know we don't want that to
happen right I mean we want to know what
we're screening we want to feel any kind
of certain relationship to that film and
a filmmaker so we meet them it's kind of
like oh you made this and then we kind
of have a kind of hit it off already you
can I know you feel like you know them
or something it's a cool feeling it's
like oh I saw your film I liked it a lot
we recited a program it we picked it
because of these reasons you can talk
about it and it's that's how you engage
more if you didn't do that this is like
yeah I don't even
yeah thanks for being here it's great
but I don't even know anything about
your movie that's the other side of that
so that's fantastic
that's drastic you know but it's not
like you know we're gonna not see the
film at all but maybe we wouldn't we
didn't what if you didn't watch it in
programming some other judge said oh
this is great you should program this
this and this and we never watch the
films with everything else going on we
put it we programming we do our duty we
do our stuff get the information from
them be the website ready schedule do
our stuff come home the festival time we
never seen a movie one you don't want
that to happen really much at all if at
all and we want to be able to know all
the films and see all the films
and experience it you know I get to say
my audience would then again this is our
fest with our name behind it we you know
we've started this so we want to kind of
maintain that like his integrity just
you know either I might be the right
word I mean you know we want to maintain
that and we want to be able to say we
know these films and these are the ones
we picked you know and not just Austin
alone of course we have other members in
jury they'll watch with us not just us
too but what we want to at least watch
with them as well and see pretty much
everything and that's that's really why
you know we want to feel like we know
what we have on our hands you know
that's really that I guess so I guess
it's partly also the trust factor I
guess I mean we yeah I think so just
trust ourselves more than others
sometimes I guess as well well can you
take a sensual that world like when do
you begin watching them and what's an
average day like for you your co-partner
Theo Dumont and then whoever's involved
and watching them go through like what's
that like well it's basically uh you
know early on it's uh it starts pretty
early I mean you know sailor run now
really now going forward you know we get
together on times we can and usually
weekends and and just sent just sit down
just and watch in a full day we'll watch
as many as we can really get there were
just a bunch of films score them and
then with the early thinking in mind we
don't know what we're gonna do with
these films yet we don't know how we're
gonna program or anything other than the
basic obvious of animation we have
documentary you have students you know
certain basic categories right but
outside of that we don't know what else
might come our way we program based on
the type of quality we get from from you
know other areas like of a sudden one
year we had French films and you know
the year we have Spanish films another
year you have films you know directed by
women you know it depends on the amount
of volume you get to certain types of
categories think so we can program
around that once we get to see what we
have that's we're watching it all the
films but until then you have to just
kind of see what is worthy of looking at
again and what is it that's initially
the early process we're gonna watch just
to be as early on lenient say okay is
this good enough to consider and we can
look at again later or is it something
that we feel after watching the first
time was just this is not going to score
high enough and it's not going to get in
and it's just kind of SAT across us so
let's go through all of that and all the
films and we kind of sit and see okay
now that becomes we have
we have the program and get into like a
sort of a second round then we go back
and ride let's watch these again and see
where they fit or compare the judges
digit scores and see where we feel
they're at or if we feel like again like
I said like say for instance female
category the female directors we feel
like I was some really strong films that
fit in your program for that alright
cool
you know what those films are score
really high let's go ahead and slap
those in that fit well with that program
we'll program that and then you know
maybe they can go back to those when we
feel like strong about how they scored
in the films that fit in that program
it'll create a program for that because
again we have latitude you know we have
the basic categories and then we have a
lot of slots to fill they're just stuff
that we can create as far as the program
decide how we want to get creative with
how we want to show these films and
audience so that's where some of that
comes into play without a pic films as
well so yes that's some of it and what
is your scoring paper would look like
like what what some of the criteria do
you what someone someone obvious right
like you watch certain film is intended
just home run you know the films amazing
you know the film was just flawless is
fantastic you know the acting was great
visually stunning and everything was
just you know just great and it just
really just you know everyone across the
board just feels like oh this is a
fantastic film and we're gonna program
as well something's gonna score very I
will make note of that of what it was
what was good about it what what a
potential words could appeal for if at
all and and they kind of go from there
and that's kind of push your side like
alright this is you know we know this is
gonna be this is gonna get in and
there's other ones where you know we
feel strong about it but there's some
things we felt we're lacking whether
it's the editing of saffat ography the
acting whatever areas of the film that
will note that you know the strong in
this area they're not as strong here and
give it a score based on that and then
we know to go back to it and we'll know
what we're looking for as far as you
know we go back you know what word it
could fit in word maybe it doesn't and
and why so that's part of that process
and then outside of all that would be
the films like that you know again like
just score lower just generally don't
you know just are not either just poorly
executed not well made or other areas
that are they're probably they're
problematic for us or just in our
opinion just just didn't work you know
and this didn't work because again it is
a biscuit boil down to a judgment call I
mean all films I mean you know we may
not like something someone else may but
uh if those don't school well enough and
then they're out
and will willing to kick them at that
time but we'll score it that way so we
know we're not going to go back to
revisit those films but uh you want to
kind of it's a sippin through process
you want it early on sip to the films
and see what you have don't have and if
from there go back and serve with a
trying to see if you'll plug in the
films we watch them compare than other
films of the same genre and things like
that and then and then kind of see what
you're at without naming any names or
you know filmmakers or whatever can you
ever remember a time when you and the
team really on the fence like there was
just a real polarization over one film
and how long it took to come to an
agreement yeah that was happen sometimes
I mean it used to have a more early on
because we had so little spots to fill
we used to be two days and then we were
33 days and in two three days you don't
be time I mean your time is just very
very limited you have to Anna it was
like two and a half it was a Friday
night and Saturday something it's really
like not even three full days we can
only show it was like 75 movies so you
know that would get really tough because
now you're like all right why are you
picking this films and it doesn't make
the process a little more stressful or
is really really why picking it how does
it fit the program we didn't back then
really program much by like theme as
much as more like we just want to try to
show the best films possible for this to
be had to be that way they'd be really
strict on that because if he didn't and
we're gonna like alright let's throw all
these these you know these kind of
slapstick comedies together and make
this for well we do that by 8 o'clock at
night it takes away two hours we didn't
know other room to program anything else
though what about that other great film
noses and testing drama that we piece
now we can't show it and better than
that of the film but if it's a program
that don't really feel it's fair but
that was then now we have seven days and
you know you may even add more we have
time to fill so we can go and do a two
hour program of just these kinds of
films and two hour program of this kind
of film two hours Docs two hours of
animation two hours of comedy twice so
we can do that and then that can fill
those spots up it kind of helps us to
lead us in certain direction is what
we're gonna pick so it's the the debates
aren't as as kind of intensive they were
because again there's a little more
leeway of time where you could fit stuff
in but well yeah there's definitely
something because sometimes repolarizing
with and I like that I like terms
take more chances but some people might
say oh that story I thought that was
really stated and you just hated it
and I might say you know what no I
really loved that I thought it was great
story that was real originals Fred oh I
was it was just ignorant I was stupid it
was this the whole so you have that you
do have films like that sometimes that
are very like just stand out a lot
whether it's just a subject matter and
that's generally what it is it's a
subject matter if it's something that's
a little maybe to be handed or just
really really dramatic or just vulgar
that's the stuff for the vulgar violence
like that kind of thing some people
might feel it's wrong about like and
some people might and I feel like you
know no I don't think this is the shitty
screen it doesn't fit and that's we had
that debated really comes out to the I
guess you'd say probably the stuff
that's uh that's more of older in nature
you know a lot of times and I might
write from what I like that stuff you
know I like the films are taking more
chances you know and and and film I get
to do that I'll appreciate even if maybe
it's a little risque or over the top
I'll lean towards that mean by
personally me personally some some other
folks on our team sometimes not so that
you know there's that debate but you
know sometimes me at the old and say you
know what this is all we like so
whatever dan what would you say
separates the films that make it into
the Holly shorts Film Festival against
those that don't get in I think uh you
know going back the story and the
completion of the story I think the
biggest thing is this kind of two parts
is one films that don't stay true to
what their story is you know you have to
answer this part of the questions we'll
go back is there's not a side of it the
obvious stuff as well but the film's I
don't complete you know they go out to
set as they stig wotton and the
filmmakers said to make a certain story
or make a certain film and tell us her
story and they go on and it turns out to
be this is trauma then it turns into
some type of uh yeah you know
over-the-top Ranji comedy and then like
that like Tutera I throw three four
drama pictures into one 15-minute short
and in the films are all over the place
and then it becomes confusing for us
during probably be confusing for an
audience and their story gets lost the
film becomes enjoyable there's problems
of the act like it just kind of sense of
some of the snowballs that way those
kind of films where people were trying
to tell or show
their abilities in many different ways
instead of just staying true to the one
story than you tell no you are dealing
with short form short content it's a
short film it's not a feature film
feature films can't have that that kind
of that type of texture and go longer
and you can kind of go into different
periods of story and you know and back
to the ring whatnot but when it comes to
short and you're not make a feature and
you don't have that same luxury and so
going back to that some filmmakers you
see you know get with cramming or in the
end they also you know and I'm gonna
just throw this out there I just we were
not a fan of the lengthy opening credits
short film I'm very annoyed about that I
just gotta know how to say yeah I think
other programmers I've talked it like
it's just something that you know you're
not you know it's not a feature film you
know it's not a feature production so
you want to give everyone these needs
that great that's a Christ that's not
the point
but Krejci be at the end those credits
are deserved but to open up with that
kind of that kind of credit sequence
without telling your story it's wasting
time you have a minute to thirty minutes
tell your story tell your story you know
and in tune of these films come in and
is yeah I guess I'm following a model
maybe they see feature films thing okay
I don't make a film like this and that's
not what you're making I mean some of
the best shorts when you simply just go
right in the story and go right into it
and I'm just don't know how much credits
at all sometimes if at all now I'm not
saying I'll have credits at the end in
mind credits at all reading credits an
opening but just these like full-on you
know associate producer credits or when
I in the beginning of the film this is
not it's not the place for that I think
a lot of programmers probably in harsher
than we are about it I'm not gonna like
say notable films so that's it it's done
but it's some of this distracting to me
and and again if you're not getting to
the story right extinct this way we're
saying we're I watching films all day or
even if you're watching a certain amount
in a day you're still you know we're
gonna be on work and I'll critique mode
would mean you're gonna be kind of
little more critical you know it's good
to see stuff again sometimes and kind of
back off that and just kind of you know
enjoy the film and you know and not be
as harsh I suppose but you're watching
stuff for a period of time if you are
watching all day against other films and
something like that is gonna be a
negative deterrent it doesn't help
doesn't help so that's one thing I'd say
you know told me I should avoid for it
when it comes up
and she worked in and if you're
programmers I think they feel probably
the same as we do on that but that part
of that does this the story again the
issue of telling multiple stories and
once in one film you know we're trying
to showcase different sides of the
talent like styles you know the maybe
they're trying to emulate certain
stylist or filmmakers they've grown up
watching so you have like again the you
not like a focus of the film no and
that's that's that's a problem it's a
problem it's a probably see a lot and
you have films are very you know that
they're the stories told and very nice
flow to wait if it's the most simple of
stories but it's told in beautiful ways
and it's executed that's what we can
appreciate and that's what we can look
at safety why can we program there's no
reason yeah give me any reason to say no
it's kind of one way we look like
alright this film had the elements
needed to have to tell its story to the
best it can be
I had no reason to say no to the film so
that's kind of where like okay then
we're gonna find a home for this program
because it just it just the film works
and there's no reason to say no to them
well how often do you see very you know
the production value is excellent maybe
even over produce films but the story is
just so poor whereas on the flip side
you'll see something that's some
handheld camera but it's a really solid
story even in five minutes
do you see a lot of that or is it kind
of make sure make sure you see you see
if you see it a lot I mean you do see
you and it's tricky because it's similar
for your stuff you know there's a
certain value there you know they may be
fillings are aggressive of the festival
they might come out and really support
and that's a way to consider we can't
stay here and say we can't we do or a
festival would still an event in
business like anything else we also want
to put the best product you can out
there compared to what else you get so
every year all the films we have in
comparing each other can't looking back
a year before the year before that it's
about what we have right now and what's
the best of what we have when we feel
it's best that we can show for this year
alone not looking at the focus now
looking back now I got the future right
now and yes you get some of that you get
these these films and well how the money
spent and and yeah this is the stories
is lacking there's a certain I guess
maybe it's a they just a certain lack of
care for for that because I guess they
feel like they have some the other
elements going forward or which
connection you spend all this money and
attention
click and do all this stuff and if the
film doesn't have a story then you spent
a lot of money for essentially kind of
nothing right okay so you see that
sometimes it's kind of it can be that
could be frustrating that is kind of
like because you want to like something
so much oh my god that's that's that's
not working and the opposite you can
appreciate someone making something
really really interesting or cool or
very well-developed fun Shore or really
good short that's done with you know no
money you know there's something except
for that so yeah you see both sides and
you want to you don't want it but do you
want to judge too much based on all that
you know because it can be sort of
unfair look at the films available they
gonna be money in the discourse more
with it and this guy that wants money
they just wasted it you know it's not
everyone I still say enough to make a
certain project there's still process in
place and I wanna under your over value
in one's process and just assume that we
had no money so this is so much better
and this one had they had also money so
they have that easy this still process
they to get that money they're still
prostate to make the film it's easy to
sit there and say oh these guys and this
money's then I just you know they just
they're lazy and it is it's that's not
fair and it's not necessarily true
because we have the discussions I go
there's you know a movie that has all
this money spent on it didn't work in
this level so you know you can't have an
inkling to like to like be a little
harsher but it's not necessary fairy I
want to do that too much and the same
with the film that has no money the flip
can be said it feels like we've said you
could say well they have no money but
they also didn't raise the money
they also maybe could have they may be
scared to make that kind of film there's
there's other there's so many things you
can really discuss on that front but the
bottom line is we don't know anything
about that stuff so we get too much into
that you're judging based on stuff you
don't even know about it got stay away
from that cuz I will go back to like
what is the movie do you like the film
is to fit the program and kind of keep
it simpler and go back to that because
if you get into too much of this here
saying kind of like thinking too much
about what it could be I don't know
anything about that stuff we don't know
these people we don't know anything
about that real history of their film
how the phone came to be so to start
assuming that stuff I don't think is
really affair so does something we have
to do is kind of have to kind of guard
against it and think about those
discussions are had you know it's
definitely you definitely have those
discussions and does someone have a
better chance of
to the Holly shorts Film Festival as an
early submission or over a late
submission or does it does it not matter
yeah it doesn't know I really doesn't
matter I mean I was gonna maybe say yeah
you don't wanna say doesn't doesn't
matter but it doesn't matter I mean the
honest truth is that you know it's
better similarly we kind of you know
encourage that it's good for different
reasons obviously cheaper for the
filmmakers and easier honest you know we
can get through the process of watching
the films and all that but we're still
going to go through the process all the
way through and if a film comes are if
we are open to submissions and we're
taking submissions and we're gonna have
to watch the film and treated equal like
any other film we're not gonna like look
at and say I love this movie but you
know they submitted on June 1st I mean -
mid last week you know it that'd be
stupid
you like you know I don't know if it'll
do that but that to me is it's kind of
moronic I mean you know we want to like
get the best feels possible screen the
best films we possibly can screen if we
feel the film comes our way - we're open
to submissions and taking submissions
that means we're still for competition
we're allowing you to submit and we're
taking your money we're gonna treat the
film equally with everything else and to
put them all in each other and in the
competition setting and see what the
best films are and they'll be up for
competition enough to be selected and
that's really the bottom line I mean
yeah I don't want to get into like
thinking of things based on just the
deadlines and all the rules so much
because I don't know what's them again
we're trying to find the best films and
if we like a film don't want to show it
then and they submit it to us me
personally if you I feel like that's
just like silly just to say well you
know we liked a lot but you submit it
too late and we just couldn't program it
well then you know we shouldn't that
point you taking submissions if we're
taking submissions still and we're open
for call for entries now granted if
assume that after deadline that's a
whole different story it's but we don't
really generally want to take some films
after the elements so yeah I guess long
answer for that but yeah it's uh you
know I guess where we're coming from
with that
there's an honor and our experience on
the other side as filmmakers submitting
the film festivals there seems to be
like if we get a film in early there's
more likelihood to get that acceptance
whereas there's instances where we
submit late right and for some reason
it's like any time we submit our films
late it isn't innocent that they're
never accepted so how do you respond to
that yeah I think oh I guess I guess I
could say I can't be speak to other
festivals but I would think that there
must be well I mean I got I can speak
dogs and sense that we do know that
there's a certain period when we are
slot in their films we're selecting as
we get closer you know we have a certain
mindset or we know or we have this many
films there that are very highly graded
and score very well so I guess from that
standpoint you are up against it in the
sense of like you know you might have
program a certain amount already because
obviously over time you see films you
love a film you see in January so the
film's amazing this could be this is up
for this award that award and it's gonna
get in so you do have sauce there fills
right but we're not gonna completely not
with the film the festivals not
completely programmed by the time we get
submissions and say like May or that's
not the case and if it was then
obviously that wouldn't be fair but also
again back to my point like if something
came our way that's like you know first
is last year Assad won our won Best
Short Holly shorts it was submitting
like you know April in the regular
deadline but if that film was submitted
in I don't know the last agent first
well if I rejected that film or well
objective based on on room for this so
we just can't sit we can't accept your
film or we just rejected because we just
didn't feel like we had time to watch it
or I don't know whatever process might
happen with some these festivals we'd be
losing out on the best film we've had
and arguably in years and we wouldn't
put it in the festival I mean at this to
me that makes sense now the other side
is again going back to going back to
pointing to the festivals and even our
you know case Waris we do have to
program as the process goes on again
slots are being filled so there is a
benefit this women earlier but another
part of this is what if your friend was
got finished and may you just finished
in wasn't it I mean you're finally ready
so you couldn't submit earlier anyway I
mean if you just got your film finished
you wanted something for this this year
and you finish your fellow man
you're done color corrected post
pressure dye everything's done you want
to submit then there's dummy not that
individual has no option but to submit
in May or late and that's the minimum
because if F was even done or maybe they
just shot the film I mean who knows so
there's that part of as well um I think
for other festivals it in this case they
were speaking on it I think there
probably is a certain process in place
where they are pretty well program or
they feel like they don't need much more
maybe they just kind of looked at the
way they feel like you don't you know
they don't need many more films and just
taking more submissions to take
submissions I don't know I mean I can't
obviously I don't know I'm not gonna
speak for others I'm just assuming um
and it is challenging there is again
like I said slots filled and and you
have a certainty of what's gonna be
where but again the process is you get
the film's we're open to submissions so
we want to compete or not them we want
to look at all the films the whole and
make decisions based on that and try to
that to be the singular focus you know
just that's what we're trying to not you
know you smell late you don't know time
for you we liked it but no oh well you
know now granted again there's there is
a sort of element of I guess you're a
little behind the 8-ball in the sense of
there's a lot of films that come our way
and in our certain film very program but
when by no means done programming by the
time we get to that point we want to
finish call Frenchie's and then start
really diving the programming at that
point you know again when you have the
competing so the films have been scored
and score high so you know yeah but
again back to how I feel about it it's
like you even if that's the case if your
film is as good as any other films then
it belong to program we'd be remissed
and not put it in the program and select
the film based something we like it
would be a mistake and what is the
submission for all the shorts mm well
runs basically we start now December of
the year before so like summer 2012 when
we go through June first so the full six
month period basically and then once you
cut it off that's that's done and then
and then at that point we're really
getting the selections and really
getting into the programming and diving
into that put up until that time we're
just do that time we're watching films
all time and the festival dates are when
dogs 14th August 15th 22nd and we've
announced earlier we were promised 15 to
the 25th we may be stretched into 10
days and have some more work on in that
and then out some things about that but
that's still in the works so 3 minimum
August 15 to 20 seconds but 7 days we
might we might take it to the 25th and
go fifteen to twenty fifth for 10 days
possibly they can go to Holly shorts
comm from defamation dan when it comes
to selecting films how important is the
celebrity factor do you and Theo think
that films that have recognizable stars
have an edge over films that have sort
of no-name talent so to speak and you
also factor in the potential presence of
these quote stars at the festival as
part of the appeal yeah Bart yeah I mean
you know anyone saying differently
probably be kind of lying I mean you
know you have to take an effect that in
consideration this is Hollywood we are
in Hollywood other festivals maybe other
cities that people can attend or that
may not be the same kind of factor we
are it is we're in the backyard of all
this you know our festival takes place
right next door to where the Oscars are
taking place in a few hours like this is
like you know where we are so that's
part of it I mean we have open night
which is always been kind of a stark
have premiere platform we want premiere
kills we want the highest quality films
and we also want a certain star factor
that's part of what hoping that is rare
carpet big event won't emerge the a-list
Hollywood with the indie filmmakers to
kind of bring that together that's kind
of been the the way we've done that
that's what lost before that night so in
that standpoint we're looking for that
but the program is a whole I mean not as
much I mean it's more about the film's
how they fit programs the type of films
they are and and just an again a
competition setting just you know which
ones are up for certain awards in which
films will win in which valuable program
and the festival we're not so concerned
with a regular program with the
celebrity factor as much as that factors
in open night most like us know trying
to get in but yeah I mean you know if
someone's gonna be attending it's good
to know we never you don't really know
that before any people could say that
all the time and you don't really know I
mean they could say they'll tend to like
the tenants nice to know at all but if
we don't like the film this is so
doesn't work and it's not something that
we feel is gonna fit opening night and I
can
program then we'll have to what to put
aside and drawing us they're not playing
the film I mean it's just it's not like
okay they'll come what if they don't
come they might not come I mean it son
doesn't guarantee anything in this town
that comes with celebrities but it's
good to know at least that people are
aware and there they are supporting the
project doesn't even ever it hurts that
you know a celebrity is like you know
backing a film and if you like the film
is great they go we want to program this
and that versus behind it I'll talk
about a look at it out there that'll
help with potential attendants and
things and people getting the word out
you know we want people to get excited
with the festival get the word out for
the festival for their for their film
for our festival and for the other
filmmakers and everyone wants a good
crowd and to mingle with stars or
whatnot but you know you also want to
just go back to again the simple thing
of is the film better not you know is it
we've had a lot of films over the years
just with celebrities and awful awful
and maybe easily rejected them I mean
there's just no you know and you know
they know we know they're gonna come and
hide I mean we don't even get to that
point with some of those films I mean
it's it's like you know granted they're
not I'm not talking my films are like
alias stars I mean that that's that's we
have had that word I cover their
bachelor stars done stuff that's of
quality but like there's stuff that more
be stars and people that are like no
recognizable faces and TV or not good
talented actors that my feeling is
they're just they're just doing stuff
for hobby and they pick up a camera
because they can and just make something
and and like anyone else it's not easy
and it's not like you can just pick up a
camera make a film make it good just
because you are such as such that
doesn't work so we've seen some films
over the years I won't name any names
but some movies are just you had some
Talia my god I was that was a wish that
would work to wish that was good because
we'd be programmable we just can't I
mean there's some films maybe some
prophets and the stuff it was again I go
back to I feel like my personal
philosophy on those films is actors with
downtime unpickable Cameron's make a
movie get some friends together we have
actor friends that are working and you
know recognizable faces and we'll make a
film and submits always festival
everyone will just love us but there's
been some films like that that are just
pretty bad really really bad he was
again they're lacking a lot
bad sound cards but you know it's like
anything else it's got to be of certain
production values from quality and sort
of filmic employer they don't then they
lack because again you know filmmaking
difficult and you have to know what
you're doing and just because it sounded
actor there we go with cameras I mean
that that's gonna happen yeah better if
they trusted someone else directors home
for them but again it's part of the
directors wannabe actors acting on me
directors and that kind of thing so
you've seen some films that no it's it's
you know you want to program a quality
film on the screen so there is a you
know it gives them a more exposure look
like you give me a chance to think about
it so I'll see that like you see a
celebrity I like this guy's great in
this so you're gonna give an extra
little maybe you give a second look
again just like I don't want to give it
you you might you know I'll be honest
but if the film is a goodness not is
just not it's not the part that's not
the part it's just no you wouldn't be
fair but also you know we found a
program you know what we programs we're
picking so we say o you who big movie oh
I did oh you pick that that's what
you're gonna that's what you're putting
on screen like that's you know I don't
want this don't want to be that's kind
of embarrassing so you know you know
that would reflect on us if he pickles
really just based on oh what sons is in
it but yeah but that movie was awful
oh yeah well what'd you say so yeah it
does go back to the quality the film but
yes I think it does help I can't hurt in
general it can't hurt to have ain't
telling your film I just can't outside
of certain fest that are strictly Indy
you know some fests are very like
staunch about yeah they want strictly
independent film they want any you know
there's some of those out there but
outside of that yeah I think it does it
does help to have name time your fellow
certainly and if they're back in the
films are certainly that question what
do you see the filmmakers who are
looking to promote at the festival let's
say they're planning to attend or a
postcard is really effective I mean they
just different places I've gone to there
in the loggia or there in front of where
the screening is do you think people
actually pick them up and help some no
sometimes you be surprised there's a lot
of there's not folks that like that that
seem to to go to screenings and attend a
night and just like the like they keep
everything like you take all these
postcards like it's not
we can postcard poked really good know
this and they said like thrown the bag
it saying they want the goodie bag throw
all these people they love taking
postcards but yeah so there's that but
us outside of that I mean they're good
it's definitely a good thing you need to
have a presence when I have something
out there is it something that's gonna
you know get you that that agent or that
deal that I magnin we can all see to say
I couldn't say that you know I mean no I
wouldn't think so but it's in time if
they saw your film get your information
from that then I guess yes so it's you
know you know with the screening someone
that's really important you know whether
it's to survey agent someone you want to
see the film come out can't you can't
you know I can't talk to you you just
busy or you know you're running around
or everyone's talking about the
screening they don't get to you or
something you know you want your stuff
out there the information it's part of
the visibility the festival it's very
important but you know with that said
yeah I feel like it's not it's not it's
not like actually imperative and it's
not something that you know if however I
mean like if people yeah I think so
people pay no sooner will probably don't
but it's it's at least some disability
doesn't hurt to have your stuff out
there I feel it's important to have
postcards and information out there and
the more you're like at the fest
aggressive trying to promote your stuff
the better
so I gets to go back to it if you put
postcards now and never show up to the
fest all we can use go to your movie I
say no if you have your postcard out
there we are there passing people or
young people hey what about Google grab
this poster here you go and if you did
then yes I mean it's it's people
remember that it's visibility if it's a
good it's a good catchy postcard with us
is the image of the film or it's a cool
poster or whatever that stuff helps you
know and if you get it out there and
every date sometimes and the screening
you know people will will will come into
your film I mean the festival was grown
to the point now where it's more engaged
people want to enjoy themselves and want
to take it in and see other films get to
know other filmmakers go see their stuff
so there's a supportive thing that goes
on you meet it overnight and you just
discuss a lot of stuff and then you go I
won't see your film most of your film
you share that that happens so it's yeah
so that is good to have this stuff out
there but uh there's other ways of
promoting stuff and that may be even
better than that of course but it
doesn't hurt to have you know I think
it's definitely good
postcards the festival but to go back to
it gonna be there you know drop your
stuff off I never be there yeah I know
that doesn't really do the job
Eriko abroad an article for any wire or
he calls out the film Independent Spirit
Awards and he says quote for losing
their indeed quotient is what it calls
it so you have films like the silver
linings playbook with like what twenty
million dollar budget dominating the
film Independent Spirit Awards who've
seen the same sort of thing happen with
you know Sundance and to some extent a
little bit with Halle shorts you have a
wonderful officer lineup opening night
it's fun to attend so having experienced
this kind of growth yourself maybe
that's sort of that flipside of the
problem of prosperity is there any way
to avoid the quote star system and
remain true the Indy or is that just
part of the growth and our they're pros
and cons and if you don't put that star
power in there then you don't have a
good model well there's a lot of ways
that it's a good question so there's a
lot to kind of cover with it cuz I visit
different ways you can go with before
one with with Hollywood's it were still
obviously a short film festival short
content we do screen some features and
we try to tie any alumni with that and
we've done special technarch screening
last year and with Joe Carnahan tying in
to the award and so there's some of
those elements but outside of all that
you know we are a short film festival
trying to make it the largest and
vegetable Film Fest that we can we're in
a different place as far as what we look
for what we're getting the content that
comes our way is different then wants
unanswered dealing with and some of
other festivals Tribeca can yeah you
know whatever I mean Toronto you know
and the Spirit Awards like their their
what their agenda is is obviously
different than what our agenda is in
some ways is always the same of course
you want the most voter you want the
most attendance you want the most press
and I even excitement for the film's for
the festival for everyone of all but
outside of that there is a different you
know different deal in place and what
like say for instigating a kin Spirit
Awards you know what they're dealing
with what they're trying to do what
Sonny is trying to do the star power its
studio driven
they're trying to support studios trying
to get films screen that will get
acquired you know there's there's uh
stuff like South by Southwest that opens
a lot of times with the studio films
kind of promote it so she's essentially
it's a marketing plan part of the
marketing plan is to open in these
festivals so they're gonna obviously
back the festival they're gonna select
the film to screen it because the studio
wants to open premiere did it with last
item and 2010 Lionsgate premiered at
South by Southwest opening night you
know stuff like that that's that's where
the studio integration with the
festival's they're on that size that's
where that happens work the I guess the
you lose some that indie feel so it
speaker you lose some of that indie
spirit really but that's for those
fastened for those situations I guess
it's you know what do you do you know I
mean you have it benefits you know the
festival benefits the people back in the
studio of the film everyone involved it
when both parties have benefit stones
it's a screen he's films so so in a net
regard it's it's tricky you know streaky
but I think in the end there still was a
lot of good independent film that that
gets playing it's love of these
festivals so I wouldn't say so much is
like all they don't get any any more
recognition or love a you know maybe not
as much these do did it has changed but
that's speaking on those pets was not
for us you know we we're seeing more
there's been a shift that we were seeing
different quality content you seeing
more star power than before nowadays
more than ever you know you can pick up
that camera make it movie people like
actors when we directed dragons on the
actor so you have these actors that want
to go to that side of the camera and do
that
the best way to do that is to you know
you generally create a short so you're
gonna make a short film because you want
to showcase your talent also try it
since you like I like practice for
someone who's got industry connections
as money they can produce their own film
if you're a list celebrity you know
what's it to you that you spend anywhere
from five to eight hundred thousand
dollars on short film I mean it may not
be much for you so that you can produce
themselves and make a film and tell the
story they want to tell and and give it
out there so obviously we're offering
that platform for any filmmaker whether
a a-list star or or just straight
strictly independent filmmaker or
student filmmaker young filmmaker or
whatever so yeah I mean you know we're
we're gonna we're gonna support
you know we're gonna have to you know
play both sides only when I say it that
way well you have to we have to support
any filmmaker with that's what we're
about but also you know we're also in
the business and we're in Hawley we're
in the business of Hollywood so you had
the opportunity to showcase stuff that's
a little talent I guess what I'm trying
to said Tom ten days of talking to
circle is what I'm trying to say is the
the back there overnight you know we
want to make that big splash I want to
really turn I guess the goal of the
festival in part is to bring in the he's
celebrity be the the Hollywood the Gersh
and the big agencies the talented
executives and the people that are
really backing films and financers you
want to bring all of that business to
the festival and have the mingle in
there interact with and see the
independent filmmakers independent on we
have so we feel the town we have is next
level people they're gonna go on to make
big films go on to work in this business
that have talent to have an i and you
see it by this efficient process by what
we select you feel like this is some of
the best stuff that's out there best
films are out there they're on this in
circuit that are playing other festivals
playing our festival when they're
premiering or going to pray at play
other festivals this is the stuff that
that these are the films that people
want to pay attention to is the
filmmakers that we'll be working one day
if not already on the verge or already
working these are the people that we
feel are are in back to like kind of
next generation so we want to bring all
that together I'm not too keen on just
like the idea like this is quickly
independent it's good on the sense of
like support in any filmmaker and and
and going that route but the thing about
that is you know we are again back
you're in Hollywood people want to work
this is not your only project you make
it short you're not trying to like this
is not like my one fellow I'm gonna make
and you're done should I make other
projects you know either making
webisodes music videos your next feature
film and then maybe another short
whatever you know but the filmmakers
goal get an agent get representation get
hired to do a job make more films
network and make films other people at
the festival where's the people in
general and that's that's the goal so
it's the next project it's it's going
forward as if there's more to come so
you know we want to bring that Dada Dada
we want to bring that aspect you know
this is festival you want to have the
event be beneficial and you want to be a
place where you can go and meet and rub
elbows with the people that
making decisions in this town and if
it's not that then you know then you got
to get there that's the goal all these
for us I feel and it's I think the goal
of a filmmaker India or not you know and
this is the goal for anyone really uh
you know I would think and I feel so
yeah so how can a festival kind of hold
back on becoming to Hollywood because I
understand your point it does benefit
the small-time each a filmmaker in some
sense because hey my short film screened
at you know something that you know
Kirsten Dunst and to me more opened up
or or joke I'm and so I get that that's
exciting and it's exciting to be a part
of it but at the same time how can
someone that's truly in the feel a part
of something that's really grown and
flourished because it's so wonderful or
is it just a part of this growing pains
I think is part of it I think is just
part of it I think uh you know because
again like you know I mean you can ask
what what is a you know what is truly
India as well like you know you these
are films are made independently
obviously but is that something that is
that the same place for the filmmakers
that where they want to be when I'm just
be able to make films a shoestring
budget and just and just and and then
what what's next for them like we don't
do they want it continue that do they
want to you know go into the Hollywood
system they're not I mean I you know I
don't know but you do want to make
connections that can help you further
your career or you know whether it is
meeting someone that can produce your
next film and I still be an independent
film but it's still gonna help you
further along the process of your career
so that's really the goal of any
festival I would think or at least my
opinion is of any festivals goal should
be as simple form to try to help
showcase a film and have them have them
be in front of an audience to be around
an audience of people they're
like-minded and also people that can
help you progress your career forward
whether they're surprised you get or
there's networking you get because
people are attending that are obviously
movers and shakers and sound but that's
the really part of it so it's as part of
the growth I mean it's it's something
that I think is necessary I mean you
don't want to do is we're answering that
you don't want to bump out you know good
independent film for the more commercial
studio driven
stuff is the right wrong word froz angus
weekend the short film festival doesn't
really kind of match up but uh we don't
want to like have that happen but again
it doesn't it's a different different
thing for us because we have somebody
film to screen you know and there's a
place kind of a place for everyone it's
not the same scenario or issue I think
for us even though we have the growth in
the celebrity star factor and all that
then then say some of the festival I
could let you try back to South by
Southwest Sundance and all that for the
Spirit Awards was her you know going
that route because they are kind of
pushing in these out a little bit
because they are looking at profit
margins and then and you know attendance
and the tension and present and please
the studios there's a relationships
involved in that so you know and all
that that goes into play there but
that's different than what we're dealing
with them why we're doing what we're
doing you know it's a different because
of the content we're showing it's just
it's a little different so it relates in
some ways but it's also just a different
different kinda animal because of the
fact that we have short films and you
know and especially come Studios we
don't have studios that are backing any
projects that you know we we they come
our way you know I've seen the short
film side so so recently Raikou founder
of no film school calm and announced
that he's making manchild
the short film before he makes manchild
a feature and there's various reasons
all of which are very valid he says the
reason to make this short is not only to
help financing or raise financing but to
you know get word out about the project
to gain credibility in the basketball
world excuse me to hone his chops in
terms of shooting pace and things like
that do you find that filmmakers you
often interact with have the same
business mindset when it comes to making
short films a lot of times a pretty good
amount of fellas we yeah good about
those we get the festival are are made
with the with the feature film you know
intentions in mind I don't know if they
have the same exact plan where it sounds
like he's a very specific plan where he
has this plan that get placed he knows
what he wants to do with his film make
the film test things out and you know
try you investors attached out he has a
certain plan in place that's probably
more specific and write better and it's
smart to do more so than some of the
film's in filmmakers we have the
because a lot of times if it's a student
filmmaker they're first-time film they
want to make a new feature but they
don't even know the steps of how to do
that but they want to make this they're
kind of not just calling card but more
of uh you know a showcase of what the
story could be you know whether it is
that you know for a few minutes the film
or you know if it's almost like the
first act or just more this is the kind
of story you want to tell this is what
the short is but they've made a feature
version would just be an extension to
that whether you know like that kind of
thing so you get a lot a lot of that
where the films that we were screening I
don't know percentage-wise but me
because there are a lot that are also is
just short films or remains specifically
to be assured not to be a feature to
tell us certain stories are going to be
a short film I understand alone but
there are a lot of films that the
intention is still Kaling the turn this
in the future eventually you know horror
category what's those are horror shorts
the great they they just essentially
want to make those into features and
just finish the script and just go ahead
and shoot a feature film on the film
that they did I say this again the
horror category for instance you get a
lot of that with the with that category
and some people are already have that in
place you know they have a script ready
and they're trying to go out there and
meet people at the festival - you know
hustle and make it happen and so folks
just that's their intention but they
haven't gotten to the point where they
are ready to even shoot a feature but
you do see a lot of that plan is that
these films and going back to stepping
something like this the festival a lot
of films we have are the this is the
first film and a journey for people you
know that are going on to try make
feature films and work in this business
and I'd make more movies this is not the
end-all be-all this is the beginning so
this is very early in the process of a
person's career and know what the
majority of these films are you know the
filmmakers have feature film aspirations
for these three stories they're near and
dear to them but it's not all of them
obviously it's a certain percentage of
them that are that are that but do you
only see a certain amount of filmmakers
you talk to they have a real plan in
place already with the short to feature
like we've seen that a few times like
last year we did have a film that we
screen the feature the year before we
screen is short and but at the same time
that we're shooting the short already
having a feature film in mind and the
budget
they're actually just getting that they
want to get too short out there a little
bit and they were already had the plans
they already had financing for the
feature they just wanted to get the
short out there a little bit to kind of
just get the word out and also just kind
of get the buzzin and word out really so
that that's a similar scenario but they
also again they had financing they
already were going to make a feature
film I just want to get the short after
they Center they shot a scene of the
film manda short got out there submitted
festivals while they're actually making
a feature film so you know the same core
story so that was a good example there
but they literally were shooting the
film already and they had a feature like
their the financing of the you know that
was pre-production in place they're
ready wait they were going so you know
but you see some of that you definitely
see some of that and then there's it I
think it's a good idea you know I think
it's it so it's one way it's something
you can show them better to show people
like this is what we have this is what I
can do outside of just you know pitching
them with nothing you know you have
something if you do have the star
attached to this star is talent that can
help financing and they're in the film
even better for that reason you know if
they're gonna see if they can see that
the persons in the film and they can see
the work and see what it is and person's
attached and literally in the short you
know that you know we've seen that
before and in our fest and you know and
we've seen that example and I think
that's definitely something that works
well sure every year you receive so many
short films that are really like a first
what 10 pages of a feature filmmakers
film is just a good strategy well going
back to what we're discussing it uh
in yes but I will say that there is
something to be said for you know the
festival itself we are screening short
films are completing completed films you
want to screen something that's you know
if it's a competition for your category
this is a film that's if it is a you
know each rama you want it to be a
completed film a drama not a hope
intended 10 page you know story where i
just it's just basically the first act
of something and just leaves you
open-ended and you're like okay this
film itself isn't complete so how do we
take that you know so you see some of
that sometimes where they are literally
like the opening act of a film so what
do we do with that you know that's
that's a challenge for us like okay is
this maybe we want a program it's just
we like
organisms with it cinematography or
two-word caliber with its editing or you
know are the directors you great and we
just felt like that this for this person
can win that potentially win that
category and things like that you know
like in the competition sense but what
about the film itself is playing an
audience if you're screening it for
audience it sort of as part of a program
some of those films are very literal in
the sense that they are made you know
very open-ended 10 10 15 pages in 50
minute but we opening of what it would
be a feature and then the movie is ends
so from that standpoint
that's a complete so how do we judge
that so you see that often enough and
that's uh that's something that you know
it's really hard to say there isn't
really good answer we program sometimes
like that so we have it partly because
of that you know we felt like you know
the film itself wasn't it felt like
wasn't done and the story was incomplete
and so it's something that we you know
went ahead passed on or and sometimes we
just like to film enough where the story
is going in an execution of the film and
the quality so we go ahead and still
program it but that is the part of it
that is that is tricky from the festival
standpoint because it's one thing to
make the film that way to showcase for
investors but we're not we're not just
at there we're programming for an
audience it's a you know there's it's
not just like every showcasing stuff for
you know you know for for industry alone
or just for a specific batch of people
which I get investing and you know so
the that's not what we're doing
and that's what they're doing and then
they might want to set up a screen for
those people independently with this
film like our there's the first few
minutes on my film this is what it will
be but that's not what we're doing so
that that is something that that's
tricky and we see that sometimes and
then this to be honest I'm not sure you
know I it really not sure how we feel
about it I'm it I like it
you know I think people have that goal
in mind and they're already planning and
they're prepping and they have probably
a script in mind and they're ready to go
so they go to a festival and networking
pitches here okay I have this ready and
it can pass on something and then it's
ready to go but the same time you know
if
you know we we are again screening short
films that they are completed film so
there's great films that are out there
winning awards the Oscar nominations
nothing is you know obviously incomplete
film or a first ten days of a script you
know type of thing those cells are are
short short films and they're completed
and they're great and their stories into
themselves that open-ended to where it's
like just an opening act of something so
that's something obviously we kind of
always struggle with all you know for
years now I don't really know we don't
have a direct stance I don't know
exactly our feeling on it just that
again they do we like the filmmakers to
be aggressive the one to be trying
progressive before the career but at the
same time it was standpoint of the film
you know you you want to screen the best
as possible and sometimes those films
because of the end of not completed
films and they may they may not be you
know the parts of the best films then we
know that in 2012 you and Theo screen
the works of the storm
and Issa Rae who's the awkward black
girl we're both prominent youtubers and
we're wondering are you seeing a shift
that favors the work that youtubers
you're doing yeah kind of I mean you see
now more than ever I think there's
there's a there's a definitely a bigger
popularity for these webseries now then
then I think we've ever seen before at
this point I mean just just case in
point the last few we do our monthly
screenings you know eight months out of
the year and it's just been growing over
the years and we we forgive a nice
Claudia's going in and the last two
screenings completely sold out huge
turnouts and mainly for these YouTube
web series that we've been screening the
some of the projects we screen are the
ones that are directly responsible for
bringing a huge audience didn't the word
out and all of a sudden people
responding say I'm coming to see this
stuff has I mean people that they know
directly you know a lot of time to
screen these people invite their friends
you know relative to whatever whatever
crew members or whatnot
these YouTube these YouTube films and
stuff that's online
where's on machine Omar some the other
sites these these these default a have
and they're the fact that people on ago
see them because they don't the screen
often they're online you see them online
all you want but to see in the episode
even older episode in and in with an
audience nobody screen people have seen
the clamor for this stuff I mean there's
the turnouts were huge and is excitement
to see these projects so I'm trying to
see that one more now when in terms of
in terms of like actually what we're
showing when we program them and the
response and ticket sales to those
programs we have the festival over here
the the the the webisode program that we
have we always program one or two
programs every year the festival of just
you know all my content this sells out
over here so you see that now more than
ever and when we first started doing it
we weren't so sure we didn't even know
if it was a good category to do because
it early on the quality wasn't up to par
with the save that could really well
made short film that some of the quality
was a little bit worse off you know
there's not as much money spent as much
time and care spent but now that's
changed the quality gotten better the
the attention to that detail is done
better the quality of equipments gotten
better the money spent because people
see also the value of where they can go
there's stuff made and they can make
money on this now it's not just like I'm
doing this for getting attention people
like us we have Facebook Likes we have a
fans people watch the video and share it
people are actually you know this is the
point when I have hundreds of thousands
of views to millions of views for some
of this stuff that's actually there's
dollars now translating for that you
know you have some of these companies
are acquiring these films not even quite
in the films are really like hiring the
filmmakers to make a stuff on their
channels so you're getting paid to or
they're hired guns essentially you're
being hired to make your content or make
content like it on some of these sites
you know if we most mewtwo but it
extends out to some of these other
distribution companies and you know it's
a that online space has changed and and
it's certainly important and it's
certainly I'm glad we do now we've
acknowledged it for years but when we
started we weren't so sure and now
looking back like wow that was the years
ago now and they look where it's at now
from the start of this webisode thing
they screen a bit party and throw them
up on a screen outside to this is an
integral part of the festival we have to
have a program for all my content for
webisodes you have to have it I mean as
a short form content festival I say
short form content cuz there's there's
other areas of commercials and videos
and trailers but webisodes and all
online content
if it's right in there and it has to be
part of a vessel and now you can't
ignore it stuff it's it's no longer just
about short films and the student
filmmaking process um you go to the film
school make a film it's all online stuff
the quality is not better and the
followings there and people are making
their own way and making their own money
where you kind of bypassing some of the
general standard process the process in
place for all these years it's yeah but
exciting I mean because it's it's new
it's it's you don't know where it's
going to go and and people can you can
just you know you can make it happen
yourself you know so that kind of nice
communal spirit you know you can it can
take place here and you can you can
really thrive and that's that's pretty
cool and that's something that up to the
last few years wasn't really the case I
was it wasn't the case but it's
definitely changed it was definitely
changed anyway you see you definitely
see it with the screenings the
attendance and the the kind of
popularity of the stuff we've shown in
keeping in mind the the Freddie Wong and
his whole crew and Issa Rae in the storm
with those people in mind what would you
say are the ideal platforms for
distribution for short films well I mean
it's different from there's different
different platform distribution I mean
you look at for instance like those guys
they're on they already made their own
you know essentially you're on YouTube
and your channels really really booming
you have you know subscribers they're in
a six-figure range and you know you're
really doing very well
that's your distribution right there or
you go to you know these are the
channels that acquire stuff or require
the filmmakers and I probably foam a
payday filmmakers to to either choir
concert or make content for them on
their channels referring back you like
machinima and the other companies that's
what that would be for them that's what
that goes for the short films
specifically more of these standard like
I guess they use were standard but the
the shorts that are made in a more
traditional sense you know for us a big
partner and any company that obviously
is out there acquiring films of shorts
HD sources D is acquired films for years
our festival and you know comparable to
some some consumers out there it's it's
a fair way to pay
I know the European distributors some
companies out there that would pay very
very well and in shorts in Europe is
treated differently there's war films
the distribution there on television
there uh you know they're producing
content like that I definitely look at
shorts in a different way they have a
much more a bigger love I guess or
respect and there's actually no money
involved when it comes to shorts in
Europe but with shorts HD the coronoid
content the festival and they're
different because they're gonna showcase
stuff onto the on TV and and you can't
be online so their deal is it's TV only
you can't be on the internet why you're
actually you know on the channel so it's
a two two two two different things right
there I mean if you have something on
YouTube that content is not gonna be
acquired by sources you they can they
can't play your film
they won't make a deal with you but if
you're in the traditional sentencing
festivals and you haven't gone online
you don't want to be online you can be
on shores HD and be on television and on
their site only but not on you know on
other sites and get great exposure there
so that's one Avenue but it's a
different Avenue then going to you to
rob or you know that because that's
there's just two different things the
way they treat it I know the companies
are like that other distributors that
are on television they don't want their
stuff I guess they're looking I only
don't want to loo do they don't want to
be on the internet as well as be on the
channel they want any sort of for the
time they had been exclusive so this is
some of the ways you can you know get
you should be sure some of the avenues
to go but they're a little different
there's the TV kind of route or it's for
the time being they acquired films
exclusive and you have the stuff online
whether it's a whole different world and
and they don't really generally merge
because again these these these TV
disagrees don't want it they don't to
buy films are on TV and that they want
on TV sclusively that was the point of
having the film both you know online and
TV HD Suzanne work for them so that's
that's some of the ways in distribution
so what's the most extravagant
submission that the Halle shorts Film
Festival has ever received and did it
work like we heard one gentleman
submitted to a festival and he
sound like a hipster gift package which
is like Pabst Blue Ribbon beer some
popcorn different things like that they
said very nice thank you
yeah we've gotten yeah there's been you
know we've got some extravagant
submissions but nothing like that so I
kind of disappointed nine years going
out haven't got anything that I figured
we got something even crazier at this
point we kind of have it that's a no now
thinking about it like it's a little
surprising how disappointing I wouldn't
mind some random beer coming that'd be
kind of nice but you know I gotta take a
second here I mean just been some movie
in the elaborative press gets the press
gets like you know sometimes people send
some really expensive press kits and now
with everything digital we want that
stuff online you know we don't want that
said we don't paper waste is you know
nothing I don't consider it I mean you
if you receive it we're gonna take a
look at it but we're not really gonna
give it a full pass from it's not
because we're looking at we want the
stuff electronically sent your Senate
press kit in press confirm ation
articles on your online submission or to
see you know - this is PDF from one of
that stuff all I know you know just that
book mail and getting all that stuff it
just uh with all the materials were
getting DVDs and whatnot it's just it's
just uh it's a lot and it's essentially
to be honest a waste of space and you
know we've gotten some it's mainly when
it comes to like the press gets we're
like they're just a full-color copies
and just like this huge book of just all
types of information and every single
player involved and and you know that
kind of stuff and you know I've had some
one submission where they give us like
they had a they gave us like like still
photographs of every like caps number
and like full makeup and flower fit and
costume and and it was like all that
kind of stuff and then it was like you
know
fridge magnet and dollies that they just
they just gave all they was it was all
this stuff it was like two members some
more stuff they gave us I don't know it
was a piece of the clothes like the
costume like there's like all this
they're just like a huge press kit and
the funny thing is it was David's
trailer so it was actually wasn't even
it was a trail of submission which we
had trailer submissions and we loved the
screen trailers but the press kit and
all that stuff was for a 30-second
trailer so it's pretty interesting was
like you know it's a trailer but they're
giving this really allows take so much
time to look through all this stuff but
the you know the film itself the film
the submission is
you know it's not even you know minutes
long so it was kind of funny that of all
things like to have this huge nail press
get big package and you know all this
stuff and printed out copies of this and
then photographs of every single you
know it's like this huge cast and all
this stuff and it was for something so
short you know like that was that was a
that was pretty elaborate we have had
some some handwritten letters you know
please of sort to come in you know stuff
like that where it's kind of why we
she's like the film and in handwritten
you know which is interesting now he's
alright who writes hand writing letters
in you know the Dear John letters aren't
coming around anymore write you letters
like that anymore at hand like cursive
and so they had some letters you know
written about why we select the film and
important it was and and and and I I
guess I gotta be honest I mean some of
those those submissions have generally
been be frank pretty pretty poor you
know look yeah I mean if they come in
with something that's with that kind of
house Charlie or that's right but I mean
you're saying a letter in handwritten
not in some sense not professional but
also just like with a plea you got to
assume the film's probably not gonna be
good and they they haven't been in that
sense when that happens that a few time
they're not they're just not you know
you know the Philip speak for herself
and you know I have to sit and read know
it that way I mean I mean even though
the sense of like I'm paid for
handwritten cursive like a long letter
not like hey thanks for looking at my
suit you know that I'm gonna talk about
that like that's nice and people do that
at school a little you know on the
business card writing a little no thank
you or something yeah that's that's fine
that's not gonna silly help it all speak
for itself but can you help us put
together a film festival checklist what
are some of the do's and don'ts and
important things that have filmmakers
should include your package yeah well
you know I'm gonna go back to the press
case stuff I mean we we do with our
submission require an online press kit
and in PDF form or in any form emailed
we don't we don't really and we've now
put in our rules that we don't accept
you know mailed press kits anymore but
sometime we're not gonna
we won't reject the film if we get
something and they sent a press K to the
mail and we're not gonna do that but in
general I think festivals will you know
they have a rural place where they say
you know we we need you know a PDF sent
in or I'll maybe online submission a lot
of box of your press kit with whatever
is gonna be whatever it's press
information articles and your bio all
that synopsis all that stuff and your
JPEG you know production steel or
whatever that stuff needs to come in for
a lot Fussell's you know needs to be
however they they require what they ask
so if they ask you to send it online you
send it online if they if not they may
reject the phone based on just not
following those rules whether it's
something held in they don't want meal
you know for us we're not as we're
looking at the film itself or not I'm
not gonna begin to concern with with
that you know someone bills and by
accident
didn't send it online and they said no
and after we're not gonna disqualify you
or reject a film based on that but uh
yeah the basic check was really is just
as Jenny's going to have it a strong
online press kit website information
Facebook information like information
about where to find more info on the
film seen those online presence having
your press kit sent in you know
production stills poster image or we're
not sending with your application and
your full informational contact info the
basic stuff synopsis bio all that the
more of that the better it shows that
people are taking consideration in time
you know it's actually have that
information available you know it's you
submit something and there's like no
information when we're acquiring the
rest can you send nothing at all
whatsoever you know that's a certain
lack of attention detail then you take
an accessory you know it's not it's not
something you're gonna make a decision
on I think you can just begun for us I'm
like you know when we're looking at the
film itself this film speak for itself
but for some festivals they will
look at their rules and be strict about
the rules they tell you to submit XY and
Z as far as press kit
you know synopsis and what not detail
information on the film and or how they
asks you to submit the film if they
wanted a blank DVD as opposed to the
market a DVD with a package on it or you
know laurels of other victories and
things like that some festivals don't
want that if you do that and their rules
are stating they don't want that they
will disqualifier a rejected film so
it's important to pay attention to the
rules and but for us we for our festival
you know which and tend to be more
lenient on that you know we do have
requirements of the basic stuff you know
what we want as far as the DVD or on my
stream you know not just a link sent
over you know we want actual the film
sent one of those two ways and then our
for a press kit and then film
information and you know stats by a
runtime while I stuff formats sent to us
but we're not gonna reject a film based
on oh you don't have that information
you know but you will need that
information but if you don't say it in a
timely manner we're not gonna you know
we still want to watch this the film I
mean consider the felt and go off that
and I just disqualified how long should
someone's Bible be I don't know I don't
know I would say not to too long in
general just because it was too long I
mean you were all busy as it is and then
any business any any industry but and
this is a particular we're all you know
working we run you run affects you
making film you know we're all doing
stuff we're all very busy you know days
to be long you know in our case we're
watching a lot of films you know we're
going through so many different
submissions with everyone has their by
order has their information you know
we're not gonna have time to like read a
three-page by you know this thing is
that you get some very long but we're
not gonna just don't have time to really
like just read that we don't even need
that much information I mean it's just
nice to see a good bio on and you know
and see what they've done it is and it's
important about I say that is nice to
see it's good to go you know I will look
through bios and stuff and see well what
is this person done was there like
background
it's interesting to note and gives you a
better a better feel for maybe what the
film might be are what you know what
they're thinking is behind their film
with what they might say in their Bible
so all that stuff's good and it's
important and great but to have a very
by oh it's just the times it's something
that redundant or it's just uh it's just
information that's not they needed or
you know it's not something I'm not
looking at the biasing all right this
person's done stuff and that's it I'm
you know I this is great I'm gonna
select a film now it's not gonna sway me
that way so it's not for any programmer
probably I don't think it you know it's
nice to see it it's important in matters
but it doesn't only slightly so I say
just a bit of Io that's you know concise
and with the main information about
someone's career it's good to get into
stuff that's really really lengthy you
know I think a lot of I think well let
me seek myself I don't I'm not gonna
read all the way through I don't I don't
think so no I usually don't so just that
long no I mean that's just just too much
what should an electronic press kit
having it it depends because some are
just uh you know production information
stills stories of them to say articles
information on you know whatever media
they have whether it's their website
Facebook clear all that stuff and that's
kind of the general simple gist of it
but see the thing is some some films
have all that you know whether they had
a lot written about them anything has
ever been written about the film you
know other from other festivals articles
from other festivals they got when they
screen somewhere else good write-ups
about the film all that stuff that
should be in there but sometimes don't
have that you know obviously some films
maybe it's a premiere they don't have
much information outside of the basic
stuff whether it's just images
you know stuff in the set stories BIOS
and whatnot from the crew and cast and
everything and so some of that
information will be in there and that's
what we'd like to see but you know if
the film is to have any kind of history
you know outside of just being a new
film then yet we can't obviously you
can't require articles 100 close written
about them yet so yeah so there'd be
more full press Kate when you have a
film that's it's gone Tamura festival
life but um they're a basics it's a lot
of information you have in your
application which is you know synopsis
information on the film bio cover letter
you know a story of you know selected
the stories of the production you know
pictures from production things like
that
and it says that some of the stuff
overall seeing or some of the stuff we
like to have